The best way to play horseshoes and
Rihanna's butt sings a song.
It's episode 36 of IMG!
Mankind has come a long way
but this concept for an alarm clock that
slowly shreds money
until you wake up and stop it is genius.
Less genius
is this guy.
Kid, kid,
shark kid.
And here's a cat with cat-shaped
fur.
Enjoy your summer with a Death Star melon
and once cold weather arrives, wear some
mittens that have a second pair of
mittens build into them,
so you can hold your child's hand
and give them gloves.
Is this the front or
the side of a man?
And this blurry face is both
one face and two faces kissing.
Can you see both?
But now a famous psychology experiment.
Which of these shapes is called
'bouba' and which is called 'kiki?'
It turns out
that because our brains so naturally assign
abstract concepts to sounds,
around the world, no matter what language
or culture people come from,
nearly 98 percent call this one 'kiki,'
and that one 'bouba.'
However this is not how to use
doorknob.
So let's do triplets. Mariachi band,
fried chicken, bathtub.
Man, monkey,
parrot.
And now let's enjoy classic cartoon heroes
as pin-up girls.
This cat can be made out of this cat
by doing this.
And this goose is wearing sandals.
People don't always listen to
rules and they can't always see the
hidden dog.
Once you find him, make a cooper and jump.
Reddit brought us Bruce Willis
loving Bruce Willis.
But here's a kid who is forever
alone.
Here's a photographer... oh.
The only thing worse is sending mail to
this address.
Clippy is just as annoying in real life,
but tattoing your Facebook friends
onto your real life arm
is awesome. On facebook.com/VsauceGaming
David showed us a
panda
dog, and Nicolas suggested a twisted
E = mc 2
that's more emo. A different guy named David
displayed some LEGO creations he's selling
on eBay.
This toilet is creative,
but these are even scarier.
Today's episode of IMG! was very
special because right now
I am in London.
In fact, check this out. That
bathtub, that is now a table,
used to belong and was used
by Douglas Adams.
A couple days ago I was in Dublin
and terminal 2 at the Dublin Airport is
very important.
Let me show you what it looks like when
you drive in. Now, if you think of it in a
certain way it can kind of remind you
of being born, except in reverse.
Think about that for a second.
Subscribe to Vsauce for more.
And as always,
thanks for watching.